An awful woman lived with her daughter and stepdaughter in her household.
She possessed feelings of hate for her stepdaughter, Ana.
Ana worked while her stepsister did nothing.
On a cold January night,...
...Ana's stepmother remarked,...
..."Your stepsister desires flowers."
"Go and find some."
Ana wasn't anxious to walk through the chilled landscape.
The cold air made her lungs burn.
She walked at a slow pace because of the snow.
Soon, she saw a group of people.
It consisted of 12 men.
Ana told them about the flowers.
One of the men said they were the twelve months and that they would help Ana.
January walked to her and made a motion with his hand.
The days of the month passed rapidly until it was February's turn.
February also made the month speed up.
Then, March made the sun shine...
...and flowers grew in the field.
Ana loaded her basket with so many flowers that she could hardly lift it.
Then, she gave a quick but polite thank you to the 12 men and returned home.
She was very eager to show her stepmother all the flowers.
Back at the house, she spilled the flowers onto the table.
Then, she told her stepmother about the 12 men.
Ana's stepmother and stepsister went to seek the 12 months.
Their intent was to ask for gifts.
They looked and looked.
They became very lost and never found their way home.
Ana lived happily by herself.